barbara jean elie bonjour bonjour que
c'est une bonjour à tous vous
auditeurs et à toutes vos auditrice vous
êtes candidate aux élections
législatives vous vous présenter dans la
circonscription du nord sans étiquette
tout à fait je suis candidat donc pour
cette élection du 11 et 18 juin dans la
circonscription non dix-sept communes
ces vases 80 mille inscrits et voilà
donc sans étiquette son parti et je je
je je je veux insister sur le fait que
je suis aussi sans mandat électoral et
que je serai 100 % députés si je suis
élu alors pourquoi vous présentez-vous à
ce scrutin je suis une citoyenne
martiniquaise je suis profondément ancré
dans mon tiroir dans mon territoire et
je suis et je pense qu'il faut vraiment
agir s'engager jeu mon slogan c'est la
volonté d'agir pour la martinique donc
j'ai la volonté je veux agir et je veux
m me mettre au service de ma communauté
comme je l ai toujours fait dans mes
activités professionnelles jusqu'à
maintenant que ça soit effectivement
dans lé lancement de chaînes de télé ici
ou en france au service d'une ministre
dans un cabinet ministériel au service
de mer de saint-pierre quand j'écris des
livres pour enfants donc je vais être
utile à ma communauté je pense que le
moment il le moment ils n'ont pas grave
et le moment est propice à ce que tous
les citoyens citoyennes de bonne volonté
s'engage donc c'est ce que je veux faire
avec mes moyens ma disponibilité me
mettre au service de ma communauté alors
quelles sont justement les deux ou trois
projets prioritaires pour la martinique
que vous souhaitez défendre si vous êtes
élu à l'assemblée nationale alors il ya
plein plein plein de sujets priorité on
parle beaucoup du pouvoir d'achat mais
c'est vrai qu'il ya quelques priorités
comme l'éducation la formation par
exemple la question de la parentalité
moi je pense qu'il faut vraiment
accompagner les parents pour que les
problèmes particuliers ou familiaux ne
viennent pas sur la place publique après
et finalement elle se transforme en
problème justement donc la question
d'éducation formation parentalité la
question de la santé me paraît
prioritaire il faut lutter activement
contre les déserts médicaux et notamment
ceux qui touchent en fait pour le nord
parce que le nord est vraiment mal
placée en termes de
démographie médicale le thème de la
sécurité aussi me paraît essentiel si je
suis élu je vais voter la hausse de
moyens donc allouée aux à la police et
la gendarmerie il faut plus de police de
proximité il et il faut la médiation
l'intermédiation sur le terrain
notamment pour pour aller vers moins de
délinquance il faut lutter contre la
criminalité et puis un autre thème qui
me paraît important c'est celui du
développement durable le côté écologie
donc finalement le lien entre l'écologie
et l'entreprise je trouve qu'il faut
vraiment nourrir une culture de
l'entreprise en martinique et puis que
ces entreprises s'adaptent finalement au
contexte qui est le contexte du du
changement climatique il faut faire la
transition énergétique la faire beaucoup
plus rapidement aujourd'hui il me semble
qu'on est à 25 ou 27 % de nerfs
aujourd'hui dans le mix énergétique
alors qu'on a excusé moi un objectif
d'être à 100% en tout cas d'être
autonomes ont pas beaucoup d'autonomie
mais il faut qu'on soit effectivement
autonome au niveau énergétique donc on a
des moyens il ya effectivement le
solaire le photovoltaïque mais il ya
aussi la géothermie je pense qu'il faut
mettre le nez dedans quand je dis de
façon peu familière et nous avons nous
avons les moyens il ya aussi des
sargasses c'est vrai qu'on parle
beaucoup du plan sargasses 2 il ya de
l'argent sur la table 26 millions pour
quatre ont je pense qu'il faut peut-être
aller chercher au niveau de la recherche
comment valoriser les sargasses est
peut-être en faire une énergie il ya
deux il ya de l'hydrogène je ne sais pas
je suis pas je ne suis pas à savon et je
sais pas je suis pas chercheuse donc
voila moi j'ai envie de m'intéresser et
parce que je serai disponible a fait un
100 % députés à ces questions qui sont
essentiels pour aujourd'hui et pour
demain et concernant la circonscription
d'une heure dans laquelle vous vous
présentez quel serait pour vous selon
vous les priorités j'ai parlé de la
santé je pense que c'est un thème majeur
la santé la question aussi du pouvoir
d'achat parce que cette circonscription
est une science circonscriptions plus
pauvres que les autres je crois qu'on a
32 % de taux de pauvreté donc c'est
énorme il ya beaucoup de familles
monoparentales
donc il faut des femmes notamment à la
tête de ces familles donc il faut avoir
une politique disons d'accompagnement de
de décroissance de la pauvreté qui soit
pro active donc je voterai si je suis
élu je voudrais toutes les lois toutes
les mesures qui vont dans le sens de
renforcement du pouvoir d'achat et
notamment l'augmentation du minimum
retraite 1100 euros ça me paraît
indispensable
je serai absolument comment dire volonté
ans sur ces questions là qui intéresse
globale dans la martinique qui intéresse
la france aussi puisque je répète enfin
je le redis un élu une députée c'est un
élu de la république donc on aura à
voter des lois qui intéresseront donc
l'ensemble de la nation française et
c'est vrai que c'est un élu qui est
enraciné dans sa circonscription et ses
caractéristiques effectivement
sociodémographiques du nom me semble
rendre nécessaire une action vraiment
volontariste pour faire reculer la
pauvreté donc vote du minimum retraite à
1100 euros tout de suite et puis
vraiment je me ferais vraiment fort de
trouver des solutions contre les déserts
médicaux et brièvement qu'avez vous à
dire et à si vous deviez vous adresser
aux électeurs alors les électeurs les
électrices je vous dis allez voter
l'opposition cette histoire vous regarde
reprenons le pouvoir sur nos vies
reprenant le pouvoir sur l'action
politique moi citoyenne personne m'a
demandé d'aller là donc j'y vais je suis
mère de famille jeune fille de 14 ans je
suis né en martinique je suis parti je
suis revenu à 50 ans dans mon île je ne
veux pas rester les bras croisés laisser
aux politiciens de la politique le choix
est le loisir de faire ce qu'ils veulent
ils sont très occupés ils ont beaucoup
demandent à moi je suis contre le cumul
des mandats je serai 100 % députés pour
agir pour le nord pour la martinique et
pour nos enfants pour aujourd'hui et
pour demain donc voté le 11 juin voté le
18 de les commencer par le en jeu et
puis voté pour moi merci beaucoup
barbara jean elie merci christine
c
[Musique]